it's been 16 16 years 16 years yeah yeah
I honestly never thought I would hear
from her again our first kiss happened
when we were six years old in first
grade and so Angus was doing something
something annoying and I was like I
guess you are so immature and then he
looked at me and he goes I can be mature
and then he kissed me and I was like all
right this was my very first kiss yeah I
don't know why I thought like being
mature meant kissing I guess There Were
Strangers to each other in a way but I
don't see you as someone that like I
don't know yeah exactly exactly
okay ready okay be careful I did have
the Dunkin Donuts snack and bacon this
morning okay
[Music]
what's different yeah what are you doing
after this
like you said practice makes perfect yes
exactly exactly yeah I was she's like a
kisser yeah